Film Courage: This question is from the Youtube
channel Tall Guy NH “What are some top things
director do or don’t do that drive you crazy?”
Lawrence Jordan, ACE and Owner of Master The
Workflow: One of the big things is that a
director talks over the performance and will
be coaching the actor to do certain things
during a performance and they will be stepping
on each other’s lines.
An extension of that is when actors are stepping
over each other, stepping on each other’s
lines, the director won’t sort of gently
try to be aware of your overlaps, overlaps
are a pain in the butt.
They can be dealt with but quite often they
just can’t and they will just have to be
looped so that is a couple.
Film Courage: What about if it’s intentional
where they are having an argument and interrupting
each other, they are both angry.
Lawrence: Yeah I mean that just sort of comes
down to sort of finely finessing your dialogue
edits and attaching they may be part of the
first part of the word that is overlapped
to the second part of the word that is clean
on the other side.
There are all kinds of tricks you can work
around it with but some of the time you are
just going to have to loop it anyway.
That’s a drag because the performances are
because unless you’ve got a great looper
they are usually never as good.
Film Courage: This question is from the Youtube
channel Robert Knees “Differences in editing
for single-camera or multi-camera production?”
Lawrence: Well I’ve worked on a lot of films
with multiple cameras which I’ve never worked
on like a three-camera comedy kind of thing
so I can only address working with multiple
cameras.
I love working with multiple cameras.
It just gives you more choices, it makes matching
easier a lot of the times.
When stuff is shot with a single camera a
lot of times frankly you are going to have
to work harder to make it work sometimes.
Again, this depends on the actor, it depends
on the director, it depends on the day.
There are so many variables in making a film.
I love multi-camera.
Sometimes when it gets to be five or six or
seven cameras it gets to be a bit overwhelming
but they keep making those cameras smaller
and smaller and they keep putting them in
the strangest of places so it’s just what
us editors have to deal with.
Question For The Viewers: What are some other
mistakes a director makes that upset the editor?